[Musique]
c'est au coeur d'un typique isabelle
olivier vous emmène en voyage
la musicienne parle des poteaux atonie
des indiens du michigan qui habitait
chicago avant que la ville ne se crée je
me suis installé il ya six ans là bas et
en regardant le lac et la rivière et en
lisant l'histoire de chicago j'ai trouvé
vraiment ces indiens potato me
passionnant et du coup je suis parti à
leur recherche j'ai eu composé un
morceau pour eux qui s'appelle pottas -
thomis
[Musique]
je pense que on a oublié un peu que
l'histoire des états unis s'est
construite grâce à ces indiens et que
l'histoire de chicago s'est construite
grâce à un haïtien quelques morceaux à
la harpe pour entrer au coeur du peuple
rassemblé dans le neuvième album de
l'artiste in between lé déclinera dans
une création les 16 et 17 octobre
prochains avec le danseur et chorégraphe
ifrad hien j'ai pensé justement comme
étant un entre deux entre évidemment les
etats-unis la france où j'habite
des deux côtés de l'atlantique mais
aussi comme un autre civilisation en
train entre cultures entre un autre âge
on est finalement tous d in between
entre deux pays entre des cultures entre
deux âges je crois que chaque discipline
va s'enrichir de ce fait de rencontres
donc l'art peut-être un peu trop conne
était dans le chapitre romantique et moi
je me suis fait connaître plutôt dans le
jazz et les musiques improvisées
décloisonner les styles pour faire
découvrir le monde isabelle olivier
débute une résidence culturel de deux
ans à la ferme de bel ébat de guyancourt
[Rires]